- That is cool.
- Well, thank you.
- I like your outfit.
I get scared when people
come out and white though.
Cause they paint me cause I'm so white.
And I was
- Like, yeah, me too.
- Again, don't get stuff on it.
I know.
I'm almost like, oh my
God, I hug you awkwardly.
I hug normal usually.
(laughs)
So wait, so you've spoken
out on how female artists
are treated differently,
which I've experienced myself.
How have you experienced that?
- Oh, terribly.
It's crazy.
They're always trying to exchange
the like job opportunities
with other things.
And I'm like, if you just came
with the sex thing before
we wouldn't waste the time
with the job thing, you know?
- Yeah.
But I mean, I just think it's different
cause I didn't think it was like that
until it started to
actually work with music.
- Yeah
And then I started to see the treatment.
The difference of like,
how people talk to you,
how people listen to
your decisions or not.
If it was a man saying
the same thing that-
I've been in conversations
that I said something
and then people were
like, mm men, obviously.
And then a guy came and
said the same thing right
after they were like, wow,
did you say- I was like wha-
I just said that.
- Yeah. They're like, oh
my God, he's innovative.
And I'm like, you know what?
- Just said it and nobody gave a (bleep)
- Yeah.
- Now you guys are hearing
because it's a guy?
- It's frustrating.
Like you make a joke about
it, but it's frustrating.
I've been in that room
when you're like good Lord.
Like it's, it's like 2022.
- I mean, in the beginning
I used to get frustrated
and go and go home and cry.
Now I just learned how to get
rude and mad and aggressive.
- Yeah.
- So I just act crazy.
So they're scared of-
- But that's the same thing though.
Cause' in a meeting, if like
a dude acts kind of aggressive
it's just like, oh he's a leader.
But if a girl does it,
she's a, well a (bleep)
sorry, can't say that.
Sorry. I don't know what else.
She's a female dog.
And so, and so it's, it's
frustrating cause it's like
I'm not a mean person. I'm
just standing up for myself.
- If they say that I just stand up
and I be like, you're
all dumb. I don't care.
- Yeah. It's frustrating.
- I don't actually mean it.
- Yeah.
- Or maybe I do, but it's like
if you're gonna treat me like
that, I treat you right back.
- Yeah. I like you. You're somethin-
I like it, I like it.
So why did you call your album?
It's, "Versions of Me" right?
So it's all these
different versions of you.
Why did you- I love this.
So this album cover each one.
The one in the center is me right now.
Or maybe not. I'm joking.
It's me right now.
And then going to the others,
just one me, one intervention,
one plastic surgery
before. So before I had-
- Oh it's because of that,
it's because plastic surgery.
That's what you mean by the versions
- In the picture yes,
but I actually have different like char-
like my personality's kind of crazy.
I wake up one day.
- Me too. I'm like how
many people are in here?
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- That's why my friends,
they- whenever I wake up
they wait 15 minutes to
see who is in charge.
- Who are you?
- And they're like, oh, let's
see who is commanding today.
And they'll be like, okay,
today is the cute one.
Let's go.
And they're like, I just have
so many people inside here.
- I like to call that artistic.
- Yeah. Right.
- Yeah.
- Right here was like waiting
here for the COVID test.
Like 20 minutes in the car.
Just like listening to classic
music and reading a book.
Yeah. And my manager was
like, what's happening?
- You're like, I'm chill.
- And then I just come
back and start talking
about the crazy night I had last time.
But the cover for the
album cover is just me
before each plastic surgery
I've done and I've done a bunch.
- I love the you're so honest about it.
Not everybody's honest
about that. That's awesome.
- Because I could- I, I am so bad lying.
- Oh me too.
- I'm terrible.
- I get stressed. I sweat.
Even if it's like a half truth. Yeah.
- So I used to work in a
store before everything
and my first job was in
a store like, and I was
I so bad at it cause
people were wearing things
and I couldn't tell
they were looking good.
So, but I needed for them to buy it.
- Yeah. But you're like
that's not for you.
- I was like, nah.
And then I just used this
old lady came this day
and she wanted to buy pants like jeans
for- for her grandson.
And it was like $75.
That was another one, like $40.
But the same kind of the same thing.
Yeah. So I said, I, I felt
like poor of the lady she's and
I said, no, lady, come here.
There is one there's cheaper.
Yeah. And it's the same thing.
- You're like the worst
salesman you don't help sell.
- And the manager came to me
and said, you get percentage
are you dumb?
And I said, "she's so cute."
I couldn't make her spend 75
if she could spend just 40.
- That's nice. That's kind.
- But then you don't make money.
- I know I'm not good at upselling either.
I'm like you can have it or not.
Or I'm fine with either.
- I was very bad.
- Yeah. So wait, so you
also posted this on TikTok.
You said two of these things
are true and one is a lie.
Okay. So 1 is change the
definition of boss woman,
2 is Kanye is on your album, and 3 is
you peed on a stranger's arm.
While it looks like Kanye
is not on your album.
- It's not.
- So when and why did
you pee on a stranger?
- It's not, I just, I just use his name
cause it's a lot of buzz
whenever you drop his name.
It's just-
- Smart.
- Just goes viral. That's
why I put his name on it.
But yeah. The definition
of boss lady in Brazil
in the dictionary was
the wife of the boss.
Like the-
- Eww.
- And I got into a crazy fight.
And now a boss lady is just the boss.
- Yeah.
- Same as the guy.
- Yeah. I didn't know that
- In the dictionary, in the
dictionary, I felt that was
so offensive, you know?
Yeah. But the, the arm, the strangers arm.
So there was this, this guy
found TikTok a day in this city.
I was going to perform and he was hot.
So I sent him a message being
like, come over to my concert.
So he came with friends,
but then they got drunk
and this friend of him
was like, stop the van.
I need to pee.
And I was like, okay.
I stopped the van.
He was peeing in the tree
and an animal touch him-
I don't know what happened.
An animal did something, got this-
he got this big bruise,
this big burn thing
hear his injury.
And he was like, so drunk crying
Be like, oh, I'm gonna lose my arm.
- Oh my God.
- And then he said, he
heard if someone pees on it
it kind of make his, makes it better.
It stops burning.
- That's like a jelly jellyfish. Yeah.
- Yeah. But it was in a tree.
I don't know the connection,
(audience laughs)
but he, he was literally
- Oh My God.
- He needed someone to pee on him
and I was getting so stressed.
And I said, yo, if you don't (bleep)
I'm sorry, if you don't shut (bleep)
I said, if you don't shut up,
I'm gonna actually pee your arm.
And he said
"A celebrity pee is gonna be even better."
- Oh my gosh.
- And then I said, okay.
And then I stopped the, the van.
We went to the bathroom airport.
My security, I was like, make
sure he is not looking at me.
And he just put his arm like
this into the, the seat.
And I got like that,
and he had his arm here,
and he was looking that way.
And my security was making
sure he was not looking at me.
And I was like peeing.
And he was like, "Target the
burn, target the injury."
And I was trying to target the injury.
(laughing)
- It was crazy.
- Your aim. It's harder to aim for women.
- But he said it way- it went away,
- Okay
- That celebrity pee solved it all.
- He said it was only
because it was my pee.
- Oh My God. I love you so much.
It is so awesome to meet you.
You were welcome here anytime.
- Thank You.
Anita's album is called "Versions of Me."
Check it out.
Wherever you get your music.